oh
how are you greeting héctor mejía with his
brief informative for today thursday
july 8 a pedestrian died after an accident
that occurred at night north of the
valley police say the man was
hit by a vehicle near
craig y lose and by  the one that if not nery
in the victim did not use the assigned pedestrian crossing
the driver who ran over him
tells us the one who remained on the
scene and cooperated with the
authorities as of today all the people with
at least one dose of the vaccine
against  coronavirus will enter to win
various prizes the first winners
of art packs and will be announced
starting at 6 pm prizes
include passes to state
parks cash and up to one million
dollars people will be chosen for
a total of 8 weeks
this program ends on august 26th
and otherwise the
clark county school district is preparing to discuss
the following school year various members
of the board of directors  iva will see the
possibilities for a return to school
in person as it was before
the pandemic
so far 95 percent
of cis students and steve are
registered to attend classes to
those who are still under the
virtual learning option  they will be given a
computer and internet access if
needed the district will talk about a
possible hybrid model as well
and now we turn to the weather forecast
we will have temperatures reaching
114 degrees by today thursday we will see
some clouds around the valley but
these won't make a difference anymore  that
the day will continue to be hot we will be
above 210 degrees for the
weekend I have a nice newspaper loose
Mejía and this was about the
Spanish illusion informative
[Music]